hundreds of people rallied on the las
vegas strip tonight protesting against
covid related mandates thank you for
joining us at 11 i'm brian loftis and
i'm denise valdez now among the crowd
were ccsd teachers and other school
district employees or mana is live on
the strip tonight with a message from
protesters
denise and brian the protesters tonight
looped around the las vegas strip here
with this pedestrian bridge at harmon
being the southern edge of their route
they say they just want their voices to
be heard
fighting for the freedom to choose a few
hundred protesters marching up and down
the las vegas strip tuesday say they
want to decide if they should get
vaccinated against covet 19. don't force
it on us it should be our choice my body
my choice heather taylor is a ccsd
employee she's concerned the school
board allowed superintendent jesus jara
to create a vaccine mandate for all
employees and while no official policy
has been made yet taylor says it's
important to speak out people should see
that there are a lot of us that you know
again we're not against the vaccine
we're not against medicine some ccsd
parents at the rally also protesting
against the mask mandate one woman sent
her kids out of state because of it my
daughter's father lives in the state of
missouri in a town where they do not
mandate masks or vaccines for that
matter freedom of choice the group las
vegas freedom of choice organized the
protest they don't agree with any
covet-related mandates across the valley
at the end of the day we all just want
to live our lives unrestricted and being
able to have the freedom to do what we
want taylor says if ccsd adopts a
vaccine mandate she might leave her job
my heart is torn and i wish that ccsd
would have to make me make that decision
some at today's rally were also involved
in a ccsd walkout where employees called
out to protest the potential vaccine
mandate in response ccsd says quote it
strives every day to create a safe and
healthy environment for everyone to work
learn and thrive reporting live on the
las vegas trip tonight orca mana 8 news
now